PROFESSOR: Hi.
Welcome to the second
special recitation
on exam problem solving.
As you may have experienced,
when you do homework problems,
you can give every
problem or even every step
a careful thought.
You may even try different
methods in solving one problem,
just to check your answers and
also to find the optimal way.
But in the real exam, these
may not be available to you
anymore, because time
is the main issue.
So you want to do things
fast but accurately
at the same time.
Today's recitation is
going to focus on that.
So we're going to look
at a real exam problem.
So this is the problem from a
15-minute linear algebra exam.
OK.
By now, you've developed
enough background
to completely
solve this problem.
So because this is
a 15-minute exam,
a good suggestion on time
spending on this problem
would be no more than
15 minutes, which
means within 15
minutes, you have
to read through the
questions, understand
what they're asking for,
and completely solve
all three parts.
Why don't you hit Pause now, and
try to complete this problem as
if you were in an exam.
And time yourself
for 15 minutes.
If you finish early, don't
forget to check your answer.
You want to get all the
credits you deserve in an exam.
OK.
I'll come back later
and show you how
I would speed up in the exam.
OK.
Have you finished?
Well, let's solve
this problem together.
We are looking at a
4 by 4 matrix A here.
As you can see, this
matrix is made up
by the examiner in
a rather casual way,
because you have
numbers from 1 to 12
as the entries of this matrix.
And in the first part, we want
to find all the nonzero terms
in this big formula to
compute determinant of A.
So the determinant of
A-- so that's Part 1--
that's equal to a big summation
of plus or minus a_(1,alpha),
a_(2,beta), a_(3,gamma),
and a_(4,delta).
So what I'm doing here is I
choose one entry from each row
with the columns
being all different.
So in other words, if I take
this column numbers down--
let me write it here-- alpha,
beta, gamma, and delta,
I want this to be a permutation
of numbers 1, 2, 3, 4.
OK.
So how would you do it?
Well, if you follow
this order, you
may want to start
with the first row.
And you go through
all the possibilities
of this alpha, beta, gamma,
and delta, and at the end,
you drop the terms which are 0.
But if you do it in
that way, how many terms
do you have to compute?
This is a 4 by 4 matrix.
So in general, this sum
will contain 4 factorial,
which is 24, terms.
That sounds time consuming.
So can you do it
in a faster way?
Well, since we only
care about nonzero terms
in this sum, let's look at
where 0 occurs in matrix A.
They're here.
You have zero entries
in these four spots.
OK.
So they all occur in the third
row and the fourth row, which
means when you make your
choice of the last two entries,
in order not to get
zero, you can only
choose within this red box.
Because you want
to avoid these 0's.
Which means the choice
of the last two entries
can only be either
9, 12 or 10, 11.
OK.
Now, if that's the case, what
will happen to the first two
entries?
Since they all have to come
from different columns, which
means when you choose
the first two entries,
they can only be
from this red box.
Which means the choice
of the first two entries
can only be either 1, 6 or 2, 5.
So how many terms
am I talking about?
Two possibilities here and
two possibilities here,
which comes to four.
So in other words, instead
of computing 24 terms,
you only need four terms here.
Let's put them down.
OK.
So we start with this
choice: 1, 6, 9, 12.
So that's 1 times
6 times 9 times 12.
Well, these are from
diagonal, right?
So of course, this coordinate
numbers would just be a_(1,1),
a_(2,2), a_(3,3), a_(4,4).
This is the perfect
alignment of 1 2,
3, 4, so the sign of this
term is just a plus sign.
Let's continue.
Now I'm going to look
at 1, 6 but 10, 11.
So 1 times 6 times 10 times 11.
What is the coordinate
number-- what
are the coordinate
numbers of this choice?
a_(1,1), a_(2,2), 10
comes from a_(3,4).
So here I have 4 in the front.
The last one is
a_(4,3), so right here.
This is the permutation
of 1, 2, 3, 4.
In order to get back to this,
I have to exchange 3 and 4.
Just do it once.
OK.
Which means I need a
negative sign in front.
A negative sign in front
of the entire product.
Well, let's continue.
I'm going to write it down here.
As you can see the blue
part indicate the signature
of columns.
So next term, I'm
going to put-- I've
exhausted the first possibility
of choosing 1, 6, right?
So let's look at 2, 5.
2 times 5 times 9 times 12.
What is the column?
What are the column numbers?
2 comes from (1, 2) entry,
so I have a 2 in the front.
5 is (2, 1) entry, so
2, 1, and then 3, 4.
3, 4.
Again, I need one
exchange to get back
to 1, 2, 3, 4,
which means I have
a negative sign in the front.
The last one would be 2, 5.
2 times 5 times 10, 11,
so times 10 times 11.
Columns are a_(1,2),
a_(2,1), a_(3,4), a_(4,3).
So you exchange the first two
spots, and the last two spots.
You get back to 1, 2, 3, 4.
But you have to do twice,
two exchanges, which means
you need a plus sign in front.
That's it.
This big summation formula comes
down to the sum of four terms.
And you can compute it.
If you don't make
any algebra mistake,
the result should be 8.
Did you get the right answer?
All right, time is
really precious.
Let's move on to
the second part.
In the second part, we need
to find cofactors c_(1,1),
c_(1,2), c_(1,3), and c_(1,4).
Let me put the second part here.
So we're looking
for the cofactors
of the first row of
matrix A. Let's just
write everything down.
c_(1,1).
c_(1,1) is the cofactor
of this entry here.
So you're looking at
the determinant of this
left over 3 by 3 matrix.
So that's the determinant
of-- copy it down--
[6, 7, 8; 0, 9, 10; 0, 11, 12].
How would you compute this?
This is a 3 by 3 matrix.
Of course, you can use the
big summation formula again.
In other words,
you can write down
this determinant-- this
formula, but for the specific 3
by 3 matrix.
But that will involve three
factorial terms, right?
Which is six terms.
All right.
Is there a way that
you can do it faster?
Just notice that the first
column of this matrix
has only one nonzero entry,
which is this (1, 1) entry 6.
So why do we just expand
this along the first column
and use cofactors?
Let's do it.
This determinant is equal
to 6 times its cofactor.
And its cofactor comes to
the determinant of this 2
by 2 matrix, which is easy.
That becomes 9 times
12 minus 10 times 11.
And if you compute this
correctly, that should be -12.
That's not too bad.
Let's look at the
second one, c_(1,2).
c_(1,2) is the determinant
of this 3 by 3 matrix.
So I have to delete the first
row and the second column.
And I read what is left
over and I put it here.
So that's
[5, 7, 8; 0, 9, 10; 0,  11, 12].
Same thing.
The first column has
only one nonzero entry.
You expand it along the
first column, use cofactors,
the result will be 10.
There's one thing that
I've forgotten here.
Because we are looking
at (1, 2) entry.
So for the cofactor, I have
to put an extra negative sign
here.
So this is actually -1 times
the determinant of this 3
by 3 matrix.
And the result will be 10.
OK, let's continue.
c_(1,3).
Let's hope the computation is
going to get easier and easier.
So c_(1,3) is the determinant
of the leftover 3 by 3 matrix.
So I'll directly read from that.
That's going to be 5, 6,
8; 0, 0, 10; and 0, 0, 12.
What is the determinant
of this matrix?
Again, you can use
the same method
as we did for the first two,
because the first column has
only one nonzero entry.
And if you do that,
the result should be 0.
But you should be
able to tell it
without any direct computation.
Why is that?
Well, clearly the
first two columns
are linearly dependent, because
the second column is 6 over 5
times the first column.
So this is a singular matrix.
Right away, the
determinant is 0.
So what is c_(1,4)?
c_(1,4) is the determinant of
the matrix of [5, 6, 7; 0, 0,
9; 0, 0, 11].
Same thing.
It's singular, so
its determinant is 0.
All right.
So that completes
the second part.
You can move on to
the third part now,
but before you do
that, just notice
this may be a good point
to check your answer
from the first part.
Because you have
all the cofactors
of the first row of A, and
if you use the other formula
to compute the
determinant of A, you
can see the determinant of A
is equal to the dot product
of the first row
with its cofactors.
So because the last
two cofactors is 0,
so I only have two
terms in the sum.
So determinant A is equal to
a_(1,1) entry, which is 1,
times c_(1,1), which is -12,
plus a_(1,2) entry, which is 2,
times c_(1,2), which is 10.
What is that?
-12 plus 20, that give you 8.
OK, at least the answers
from the first two parts
are consistent.
So by now, you should be
more confident to move on
to the third part.
I have a problem of space.
So please allow me to
put the third part here.
I'm going to come all
the way back here.
So that's my third part.
What is the third part?
Third part asks you to find
the first column of A inverse.
Well, it seems that involves
more computation of cofactors,
but as many well
designed exam problems,
the answer from third part
can be directly derived
from the first part
and the second part.
That's how you should do it.
So what is A inverse?
The formula for A inverse is
equal to 1 over determinant
of A times the transpose of
a matrix C. This matrix C
is composed by
cofactors of matrix A.
We want to find the first
column of A inverse.
So the first column
of A inverse should
be one of our determinants
of A, this constant,
times the first row of
C, but transpose, right?
So I have to put here, first
row of C, but transpose.
Determinant of A comes
from the first part,
and the first row of C
comes from the second part.
So I just copy what I have
from the first two parts down.
That's 1 over 8.
This column vector will
become [-12; 10; 0; 0].
That's it.
That completes this problem.
Have you got your answer right?
OK, before I finish,
there are two things
that I like to remind you.
First, as you can see,
this is an exercise
on the big summation formula
to compute determinant of A.
In previous recitation, we
practice using the combination
of elimination and the
method by cofactors
to compute determinants.
But we should never
forget this formula.
Because it always works.
And in a lot of cases,
this will turn out
to be an easy way to
compute determinant.
For example, for
this matrix A here.
And second, in
your real exam, it
would be really helpful
if you can put down
your work like this, because it
helps you to check your work.
And also, even if you don't
get your final answer correct,
this may get you
some partial credits.
OK, I'm going to stop here,
and thank you for watching.